all right today we're going to be as
crusty as we could possibly be we're
going to be contrarian we're going to
complain about things that you're
otherwise being told are the best
practices in software architecture which
they may actually be we're not going
that badly uh so today just quickly a
little bit uh first before we we get
later into this and you're wondering who
am I to question some of some of this
wisdom coming down from on high from the
Uncle Bob's of of the past so I'm Jerry
Miller this is my third time third time
speaking in DC uh woodwind here in 2020
to finally finally meet oscar but the
world had other ideas in 2020
um I'm a long time open source developer
in inside of.net specifically I want to
call out structure map not that it's an
exciting project structure map was the
first production ready ioc container
in.net so
in about 30 minutes when somebody are
shaking your head saying this guy
clearly does not understand dependency
inversion I I do got me a little Slack
um that's going to come up a little bit
just just my experience have also having
to help other people through using some
of these tools in my daily work today
for the moment I am the senior director
of software architecture at media
analytics that's a medical analytics
software company in the US and Ukraine
um in the next week or two I'm going to
be transferring
um starting my own company called Jasper
FX
software and that is going to be all
about services and product offerings on
top of some other open source tools the
the Critter stack over in Martin this
talk is not about those things but some
of the work we're doing with those tools
is definitely informed by our
experiences working with with big
long-running architectural
long-running Enterprise systems and I
want to show you some of the ideas that
we're trying out to kind of go off in a
little bit different direction but
that's later
all right
so
the last last five to ten years uh
through Consulting gigs working in
product companies
um whoever it's in working with large
companies smaller product shops that
nevertheless built very large systems
and even working with with some
charitable foundation work
consistently seeing some Trends across
very large very long running systems
we're talking about systems that have
been in very active production for five
to ten years
where the problems start to happen the
code has been very hard to follow to
reason about one of the systems I'm
helping with right now it's very
difficult to predict that hey if we go
into this one place if we cut if then
statements and do a little bit of
conditional logic here for this one
specific customer off the side does it
end up shattering the business Logic for
a bunch of other customers down the line
it's just very hard for us to know call
Stacks are big the consequences are not
really clear that's a problem
some of these code bases are very high
friction code becomes scattered all over
closely related code becomes scattered
all over a very large solution the
things that you care about at that very
moment are not necessarily right
together in one nice tidy little package
that's a problem
upgrades upgrades are very hard
um just pulling something something out
as an example we have a very very large
system at work that uses in hibernate
once upon a time I think I was part of
the in hibernate Mafia even though I
hated that name and heavily invested
that as a tool but it's had its day it's
it's aluminum wiring not as many people
understand it today our younger
developers which means everybody but me
now
our younger developers are not familiar
with it EF core Dapper other tools
vastly more googleable that's a quality
all by itself we'd kind of like to hear
we'd kind of like to Mosey on from and
hibernate but in our giant monolith
application nah too big can't do it
performance is a problem
not necessarily because people are
starting out to write slow code but when
these systems get big and I think it's
especially around the databases it's
hard to understand where are we making
Network hops where are we making
sequential database calls where deep in
this call stack are we making even
similar calls to the database but we
can't really see it because the code is
too spread out performance problems
creep in really badly when the code just
gets big and you can't see it anymore
now all these systems were written by
people who cared about their jobs
all of these people they had a plan they
started out with a well-defined
architecture they were they were coming
to conferences like in DC they were
going to the workshops on clean
architecture onion architecture whatever
it's going to be but the problem is
everything works up front
so
That's Mike Tyson originally uh I was
going to do like a Elmer Fudd getting
knocked out and I went for the meaner
one too
so Mike Tyson's quote years and years
ago he had some high-profile fight
coming up when when people still paid
attention to boxing and they were asking
him hey Michael Spinks says he has a
plan on how to beat you or maybe it was
a Vander Holyfield I don't know and he
says hey everybody has a plan until they
get punched in the face
right
software architecture everything works
at first whatever you pick
is probably going to work absolutely
fine in the early stages of a project
that's when you're paying attention to
things the most so you're going to find
problems and alleviate problems that's
when the use cases are simpler so
potential frictions aren't necessarily
showing up yet so you got to be careful
this this project plan we started with
is architectural idea it's great right
now all of the absolute worst systems
I've seen in my life has been from
somebody purposely consciously
professionally picking an architectural
plan and following it but following it
even when it stopped working
all right
so um any any other Generation X
programmers in the room
okay
just a few hints so I originally did a
version of this this talk for my 19 year
old son and I was going to try to use
the the Alanis Morissette isn't it
ironic you know so the 10 of you now
have that that song just buried in your
mind for the rest of the day but my son
had no earthly idea what that was so
instead I went for the classic 90s movie
right
so
I but ironically uh the some of the
elements that I think have led to these
big systems being hard to work with are
exactly the kind of things that we are
told that we maybe we believe are
exactly what you use to make these
systems be maintainable
hexagonal architectures clean
architecture
the onion architecture and then I
admittedly I have a special hatred for
the onion architecture the the this is
somewhat personal that leads people to
trying to do unusually complicated
things with ioc tools which means they
usually end up on my doorstep asking for
help
it's a little bit of bitterness there's
an older older form another prescriptive
architecture called idesign that is all
about how do you divide responsibilities
in an architecture
where do you put service boundaries it's
prescriptive architecture it has a lot
of good stuff with it but it can lead to
a very over complicated system that's
slow
um
database abstractions we'll hammer on
this a little bit later you know we we
know we think we want to abstract the
database a little bit maybe for
testability maybe we think we swap the
database out layer later maybe that's so
maybe it's not but what database
abstractions can do is it reduces your
database technology to a least common
denominator approach
um it also
I think gives developers an incentive to
go down to pulling out a single entity
at a time and it's going to make you
chatty and potentially make you very
very slow we'll get into that
anti-corruption layers you know we know
that in some cases we don't want to
share our Rich domain model entities
over a web service so we'll put some
kind of mapping layer in there
specifically to not share types
go too far with that
um
that's why I design shows up go too far
with that and what you do is you add a
lot more mental overhead to understand
the system how many jumps does any data
element in the system go through mapping
layer to service layer to mediator to a
command over here everything you do for
the sake of loose coupling also comes
with a little bit of cost of just extra
junk to try to keep track of
and then finally we're definitely going
to talk about prescriptive coding
structures and here what I mean is
one of the early days of my current
position I was asked hey Jeremy can you
put together a reference architecture a
reference template for what
microservices or services are going to
be and I
partially out of laziness somewhat out
of hey that's actually kind of dangerous
when you set up a detailed reference
architecture we'll get into this a
little more the the key risk there is
people will actually follow it
all right so
I think it's probably going to come out
that I'm going to bash on the clean
architecture the the onion architecture
the what all these prescriptive
architectures are the things that you've
probably already gone to workshops for
today Ian Cooper has a great talk on
clean architecture I want to be a little
bit more nuanced here these aren't
necessarily horrible things by
themselves but there's some bad that can
creep in with them so we'll go to this
old folks thing which again my 19 year
old had never heard of we don't want to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
the elements of good design that the
clean architecture gives us we want to
keep that the problems that it that it
will incur in large systems let's try to
throw that out with the bathwater
it's just just kind of getting a kind of
a general sense make sure we're all
together on what we mean here by layered
architecture and here I'm talking about
the whole category of hexagonal
architectures anything any architectural
style clean hexagonal itself ports and
adapters the onion architecture anything
that
tries to make you think in terms of
technical layers or layers of
responsibility that's what I mean here
these architectural styles are great
they promote the idea of separation of
concerns the idea that I want to get my
infrastructure out of my business logic
that's going to be very important I
think that's very important
they give you predictable rules
developers don't necessarily have to
spend a lot of time thinking about where
should this code go just follow the
rules and the code goes where it goes
whether that's a good idea in the end is
is not as black and white as the rules
say
all right
this all sounds great
tons of
tons of workshops people doing
pluralsight videos a lot of you are
probably having success with this today
and I don't want to take that away from
you I think in limited perspectives we
have had success in my own work but this
comes with some problems
when these things go off the rails
I'll switch the code there's a little
bit of contrived
except what's not contrived is it's
absolutely real
so what you see in one of these large
systems
yeah this is not admittedly.netcentric
but we end up with
having a separate project a jar an
assembly for every technical stereotype
of the system when you start out small
that's no big deal you have your domain
you have entities in one place down to
another one there's infrastructure I
copied this from somewhere so it's not
as
be
it's a junk drawer lots of Base types
the entities what happens when there's a
hundred different classes in your
entities holder which I've seen
multiple occasions
you get to a point where finding the
code that you want at any one time
hopefully you're good with your IDE
shortcuts you know got to do that no
matter what but closely related code
making changes in the system making a
simple change of hey this customer has
this extra data element or maybe they
their workflow is a little bit special
our customers God love them they just
kill us with exception cases right
um
when we have to go and change one of
these systems built on this kind of
layered architecture approach you end up
doing shotgun surgery
write a little bit of code up here
come and make a little bit of change way
down here another change way down there
when you're writing it you get the
boiling frog problem you don't notice
this at first when you're just dropping
a few new classes in this adds up when
you get really late 10 years later five
to ten years later I despise this kind
of layered architecture if you see me on
Twitter gripe about clean or onion or
whatever it is it's this
this needs to go away
a couple other problems that show up
we'll get into just a second later so
already talking about how to ameliorate
this a little bit
um and this talking at this point of
talk I always make some kind of joke I'm
a real developer that's why I'm not
super great with PowerPoint I'm always
awkward with this stuff
oh I reordered it
oh my goodness I'm sorry folks
hmm I thought I reordered it so one of
the ways to really write this so those
layers we were off the rails when those
those layers become very huge part of
the research I was doing to get ready
for this talk make sure I did an okay
job while my flight delays kept piling
up today
um
one of the things that proponents of
clean architecture will talk about is
well you can upgrade you can easily
upgrade uh your application or you can
switch database engines right
everybody's everybody's heard that at
some point and
if you've got a good abstraction right
and you switch databases no not really
in reality in reality if you have a
large enough horizontal layer you are
not able to practice practically upgrade
because it's just too much regression
testing no matter what even if you got
the best abstraction in the world which
you don't because databases are actually
different
um we just don't have the time we can't
tell product owners we can we just can't
take on upgrading that whole horizontal
stat horizontal spread all at one time
it's just not practical
Instead This is the mild change
a lot of the issues my whining with with
layered architectures can be ameliorated
by what folks can now call vertical
slice architecture
just the idea that I am going to
organize first by cohesive features
within the system
a bit of functionality and I'm trying to
show this here I'm showing separate
databases it doesn't necessarily mean
you're automatically having a giant
modular monolith that's targeting six
eight totally different databases just
that if a segment of the database
whether it's a schema a set of
collections if at least between features
could be a little bit Loosely coupled
from each other that even if you're a
monolith if you could do upgrades this
at a time one feature at a time
that's practical you can convince
product owners of hey we can do this
upgrade in our case it's it's not
necessarily an upgrade it's
cheap right we kind of like to replace
SQL server with postgres and some of our
big systems just purely cost savings it
would be nice if we could do that
if we could tackle it more bit wise a
Sprint by Sprint we could deliver in a
Sprint we could deliver switching part
of the app from SQL Server to postgres
but there's no way in hell within one
Sprint we could ever do the whole whole
horizontal layer that's something to
think about
other weakness
layered architecture they talk about
well you can reason about one layer at a
time you never reason about one layer at
a time you reason about one use case at
a time the full vertical stack hopefully
you can concentrate on only the business
logic or only the data access logic but
likely when you have customer problems
when you have integration tests failing
you need to trace tightly related code
from entry point to controller level to
data access layer to service level to
entity the tightly related code put it
together keep it as close together in
your code as you possibly can
that means you're going to lose out on
some of that that rigor that people try
to do through project references people
try to force this kind of loose coupling
rule by setting all those kind of rules
of you know this project can only access
that project and can only have these
Tack and all that that's great
um it's extra overhead it's extra
friction on you it's just better if
developers can be disciplined instead
okay
I want to keep harping on keep harping
on a little layered architecture just a
little bit so now you start talking
about advice
all right your reference architecture so
you'll download people have these things
all over GitHub here's what a
microservice would look like and I'm
going to have a controller that calls to
mediator level the calls to a service
layer the calls to a repository
abstraction that's hopefully persisting
entities and talk to the real database
right
that consistency is great except what
happens in reality sometimes I just find
out it doesn't work sometimes it's
unnecessary complexity you see shallow
pass-throughs everybody's probably seen
this in their code right following a
template you see nothing but a service
layer that just immediately delegates
the next layer down that's silly I think
a much bigger problem is when these
things become way too bloated
so we switched it code just one quick
second here
the other killer problems
um I'm always kind of kind of lame
um let's say our problem problem is an
invoice
so a really common practice is to try to
organize these controllers and
repositories and entities around really
crud-centric thinking saying that let's
have a folder or let's have an invoice
controller which means we're going to
have an invoice invoice service and
invoice
repository so on and so forth right and
this is all spread out all over the
system
what happens longer term
you get a lot more operations than just
crud as this grows I've seen plenty of
cases where these controllers can have
10 to 15 different operations so you end
up with controllers that just have
massive dependency lists because you
have all these unrelated endpoints that
everything that touches an invoice
or an order or whatever your entity is
you're going to have one big method here
that calls one big method here it calls
one big method here so on and so forth
that gives developers a disincentive to
think about what else should be there as
use cases grow much much larger
by having one method one calling one
method one method one method one method
it's a disincentive to start extracting
methods out because
you really have a junk drawer of
unrelated operations that just Loosely
follow under the Aegis of an entity
so developers I'm sure some of you've
seen this developers will bloat these
things like crazy because that's all the
template says to do
right what they need to do instead is
they need to be breaking out of the
template they need to realize hey in
this case that template no longer works
we're going to come back to the
organization by entity because I think
that's that kind of crud-centric
thinking based on nouns I think that's
actually a root cause of a lot of the
bloated problems in these kind of big
systems but first let's contemplate
Winnie the Pooh for just a second
um
well I get a drink
so
out of this this whole whole talk if
there's one and only one thing I want
you to take away from this
um
most of us here are probably technical
leaders within our within our
organization or are you certainly aspire
to be
Fair statement folks
right so you probably learned this
lesson the first time out I was a
technical leader SEC first time I was a
technical lead I just did all the coding
and had the other people do nothing the
second time when I actually tried to be
a tech lead
um I learned a horrible lesson
um I tried to write out in great detail
because I was getting yelled at so much
for not giving enough guidance so I
wrote down this really detailed guidance
of how to do a coding task and handed it
off to the developer and when I got the
code back it was horrible
what was horrible about it I'd given him
the wrong advice and he had just
followed what I did he didn't think it
he didn't question it didn't change just
did what I told him to the the hard
lesson I learned is
when you're giving technical advice
technical Direction it's much more
important to explain the why why are we
using this template when is it
applicable and also creating a decision
tree of when does this not work so that
this advice that I gave you thinking
about these three use cases when you hit
use case four that's something totally
different you have some tools to know of
hey this is wrong this this doesn't
apply I should do something different
trying to avoid that problem with
bloated controllers bloated service
service layers all right now there's a
balance here we do these prescriptive
approaches so developers don't have to
think all right just proceed and do
problem is it doesn't work it just
doesn't give you good results in harder
harder systems so technical lead
always got to be explaining why are we
doing things understanding trying to
explain the rationale and always give
the other developers space to challenge
what what we're doing and always have a
little bit of room to innovate when they
hit into something different or at the
very least your very most Junior
developer should at least be comfortable
coming back to you and saying hey
this just doesn't seem to work
what do you think at least getting that
kind of negative feedback of hey this
reference architecture it ain't working
for me
so um going for more Gen X this is even
a little before my time you know so
we're criticizing a lot of things we're
going to criticize more database
abstractions a minute but what is good
Conan what is best in life right
um
what I'm going to say it's not
necessarily the stuffy rules who can
call what project structures reference
architectures it can be helpful but that
stuff's
um at all times you want to keep very
closely related code together as close
as you can you want to be able to work
at the speed that you can think I want
to even be able to and we'll show sample
in a minute I want to be able to just
put put controllers that call services
that call mediators I want to put it in
the same file while I'm working on it
from the beginning it's real easy that
way I can just scroll up and down I can
think all the time I don't have to
distract myself with remembering this
goes in this folder and this one goes
there
um the single biggest thing what I would
say the single most guaranteed and
reliable way to get the quality in any
code base it's iteration and adaptation
it's that is the only perfectly reliable
way to ever get to something good so you
want to purposely choose to work in a
way that makes iteration and adaptation
possible and easier so having effective
test automation coverage I think is
actually more important than the rules
about layering and abstractions and all
that kind of thing that gives you
reversibility this gives you the
ultimate ability to change make the code
soft and change the code and when I say
effective here I mean it's fast you can
run it locally anytime you want
obviously I'm griping a little bit about
selenium Suites here
it's fast it's reliable you can count on
it it's relatively comprehensive
again going down that theme of iteration
I want to use lower ceremony code and
what I think there is an example I'm
thinking of in our system we
it's a good thing we adopted open
Telemetry very early on but we've
adopted it much earlier than our
messaging bus Frameworks had it so we're
manually writing open Telemetry tracing
calls in every single message Handler in
some cases
right that's not hard code but it's
ceremony in its bloat now we hit cases
where we're finding message handlers
that really need to be broken up for
various reasons actually in this case
it's trying to open a connection make an
external web service call come back and
finish the transaction out it's horrible
on your database we want to break this
up and be doing multiple calls but to
break up those message handlers we have
to recreate all that open Telemetry
tracing that's extra ceremony but
instead you know as we move into newer
tools or just upgrade the tools we have
if you don't have to manually do those
extra explicit steps it's cheaper it's
lower cost for you to
change change your message handlers
break them up
dropping down the bottom we've covered
some of this
um
we're about to go into database database
right now
so what I'm going to tell you is I think
the absolute most important thing for
business logic is to keep infrastructure
concerns out of your business logic
I didn't necessarily say abstract the
database
that may be the answer but the single
best thing you can is keeping all
technical concerns out of business logic
or workflow logic and we'll look at some
other approaches that doesn't
automatically mean database abstraction
but that that's important okay
um and then
something to soften this up again with
these stuffy rules of you got to build
up you got to build an adapter interface
so that you can swap out the database or
stick an in-memory database in blah blah
blah this is something something I think
has been a big change in the last five
ten years is we're starting to have more
and more Technologies where it's
actually relatively easy to incorporate
them as integration tests
um and if your technology is easier to
Easy in integration tests
I'm not going to worry so much about
pulling layers and adapters and
in-memory stuff I'm just going to code
through the real stuff and as long as my
testing is good and fast I'm happy with
it
okay
so obstructing the database is it a good
idea is it not
um and it's it's it depends it's always
it depends
we switched code
oh I'll make the code really big
oh the font here
oh yeah hold on like I said I'm always
conquered with this stuff man
you heard my bad joke of the the the
people who are really good with AV it's
because they don't code
it's obviously not true
all right so this kind of this kind of
eye repository of tea
um I don't know how common this really
is anymore it was really common a decade
ago I see it pop up
um I think this is really problematic in
the end I think this causes more harm
than good especially with a bigger more
complicated system this is a very close
reflection of exactly what the
underlying technology does
um it just doesn't add a lot of value
it's pretty well close to a straight up
password
and then
y'all have
believe me
and also again go back to this idea of
crud
um
trying to organize code around entities
it's not really how it works in the real
world
um it's just very common you're going to
hit operations where you're Crossing
into different cred boundaries
you're using different entities you know
here I'm making up you're touching a
user you're touching an order you're
touching an invoice at the same time and
now I need to have a transaction
boundary around all of these and and you
have to get those transaction boundaries
right you cannot screw that up or your
system is going to be really bad so now
you might start adding more unit of work
abstractions so you get these these
really bloated controllers where they
just pull in so many different
dependencies
because they need a separate repository
for whatever it is the underlying
persistence Tech probably probably would
happily let you use one thing
okay
you just try to make the point here
so here's a version of invoice
repository just to basic crud operations
in this case I use Martin because I
wanted to
um it's mostly just just pass through
except right off the bat this is common
I'm committing transactions in here
directly
um so right there you're kind of losing
your ability to do transaction
boundaries between multiple operations
which absolutely happens
see that as easily
more problems with this kind of kind of
Repository
so
performance issues one of the very
common causes of performance issues it's
database chattiness
this kind of database abstractions like
oh you can swap out Dapper for for a
hibernate or EF core it forces you into
lowest common denominators you're not
using the power of a system so here I
wanna
jump into something real quick
which is going to require me to remember
where I put it
sorry folks
okay
oh and then I immediately threw it away
last conference I did they would not let
you do live coding they made this big
thing of you're not allowed to do it
everything you have to have like every
code sample saved to a static file
because we just flat out don't trust you
so
this is using a little bit of Martin a
little bit of Martin but let me explain
what what mark because again this isn't
a modern talk
um let's say that we have an operation
where uh we're this is a banking
application I'll use in a little bit at
one time we need to get both a user's
bank account and some customer
information so we could pick off things
like email preferences whatever that is
so we need two pieces of closely related
data
uh with the database I'm using a little
bit of of barely Advanced smart and
functionality to go grab these two
related documents in one database round
trip right anything you can do generally
with databases to avoid database round
trips to batch up queries to grab data
at one time to avoid doing sequential
calls all right that's that's going to
be a performance boost or flipping that
around the other way in plus one query
problems where you query a bunch of data
and then you Loop through the data to go
do other queries that's a pretty common
performance problem so I'm using right
here just the point is I'm using some
Martin functionality that's specific to
Martin that really doesn't necessarily
fit inside of that that very thin
what I call prophylactic abstraction you
know the ibase repository it only lets
you work on one entity at a time there's
no concept of batching queries or or
getting included included things
looking at other problems
again trying to use the power of your
system
um and and to some degree this is
this is a little bit based on
me having a lot of investment in
building developer tools
because it's obviously a frustration
when you try to build a really good tool
and then somebody puts a bad abstraction
around it that throws away most of the
power
look at the code that's highlighted and
this is.net Centric
um let me kind of talk about this
directly expose exposing I queryable
that is is the programmatic uh strong
type type querying language inside
of.net
various tools have very different
dialects and support for for iqueryable
even if you're trying to do it within
memory approach I've been burned very
badly when an in-memory approach behave
very very differently from uh in that
case back then it was using Raven DB
where we weren't using Raven DB indexing
in an intelligent way whatsoever because
it was behind a naive abstraction you
got to watch out for that that's a world
of trouble trying to abstract away I
queryable behind an eye Repository
but folks still do it
okay
let me get it back here
so just kind of review do you track the
database or not
I don't think I would even bother the
things that are simple add delete
save changes I personally wouldn't
wouldn't bother it's just not that hard
to do find and replace if you want to
swap your tooling but more importantly
if we are breaking your system into
modules where it's easier to upgrade one
module at a time I don't think we need
so much of that overhead of of the
database abstractions that's my thinking
about it we'll get into testing in a
second too
all right
um let me gosh it does
talks going faster than I thought it
would
all right one of my claims
one of my claims is that if you just use
tools that are actually quite nice to
use in integration testing yeah not to
worry about about coupling so Martin
uh Martin is a librarian that let's use
postgres is a document database on top
of postgres
document databases kind of Awesome
there's no orm mapping
this is a Json serialized version of
your data your data can be you can have
Rich types it can be nested objects it
can have collections it can be all kinds
of things it doesn't really matter as
long as it's realizable there's very low
friction in putting it together
all right so in tests
let's say uh let me look at the actual
Handler here
I'm going to build a message Handler
um I want to
show this message Handler
okay
um message Handler for withdrawing funds
from a bank account
a little bit of logic you know we need
to look up what's the current account is
we need to we're going to execute a
command
I'm going to use Martin to save data
which eventually is all it's here so a
little bit of branching logic if the
balance is lower than accounts minimal
threshold then we're going to raise
another low balance
see Tech
you know for me having a college age
College age son you know hey he's his
bank account's way too low because he's
going out to eat way too much right
um that kind of thing so I want to test
this this logic and certainly have
that this isn't a point where it can be
unit tested we'll see just pure pure
integration
so using tooling that is first
integration test
friendly
so
this one's a big thing
um Docker for local dependencies and
development development time
yeah there's quite a few hands so I
think that's
I think that's been like one of the best
things in the last 10 years being able
to spin up databases rapid queue little
things just on the Fly being able to
trash them stand them up whatever it's
going to be that's very developer
friendly that's integration test
friendly in the case of Martin that's
all I've done here is I've just spun up
a little postgres container
um without doing anything else
um let's let's look jump into a quick
little bit of a test harness
um the Cinemax unit mechanics X unit I
think is a little awkward for
integration
um this is uh this is effectively using
um
web host Builder this is just spinning
up the actual application spinning up an
eye host
using some other tools here doing a
little bit of Wolverine stuff
and Martin has a feature
specifically for integration testing
we're going to say if I need some
reference data for testing I can just
kind of establish a baseline set you
always need that kind of thing
um
just here just so that when we spin this
up in tests completely from scratch
Martin can fill itself with Baseline
reference data so you can go to go to
town start working
so a shared app fixture that's just
standing up our application it's running
the I host exactly the way it is it's
running our program program.main
[Music]
so I personally like to do integration
testing just take the normal application
a little bit stand up it's got Martin in
it it's got Wolverine
um stand that up in tests so you're
using the ioc container built exactly
right just some little extra stuff
the test itself
building the test harness
uh to have a clean database per
you know this does cut our ability to to
parallelize tests but just go with it
for now
every test for automated tests work you
have
known input
so if it's in this case because it's
built into Martin if it's really easy to
tear down a database say it and reset it
to exactly a known State your tests are
more reliable way more reliable than
depending on external scripts to set a
database up so now
let's do a little
so now you can finally have a real
integration test where I set up well if
I have an account
and I'm going to write that to the
database so it's already there
now again this is a little more helping
functions around Wolverine and Martin
this is its test automation to say all
right I'm gonna go invoke this message I
don't know wait for all activity to be
done so if it spawns extra work wait and
finish it and then finally I can go
I can go kind of check well I'm just
going to load the database and see what
database changes were made you know
still more work than unit testing but
not a huge amount
and then I can even track
um hey I rigged this up
um
now we could we could have checked to
see if it sent the low balance detected
message as necessary
all my point there besides sneaking in a
little bit of sell job on Martin
Wolverine just point there whether it's
microservices or something else if we
can pick technology that plays nicely an
integration test
you can go with a much simpler approach
you can use you can just use straight up
procedural coding as long as
so that's integration testing now we
talked quite a bit about keeping
infrastructure out of the database or
excuse me keeping database out of your
business logic
the go-to move is to wrap wrap info wrap
abstractions around the database so you
can mod it you can stub it
that that is an approached and maybe
what you want to do
but the biggest thing is
um I like what Jim Shore describes as
the A-frame architecture
uh let me just kind of kind of show an
example here we're going to go to Wolf
Wolverine
so this withdrawal funds Handler
this is the message Handler here
um this is this is Wolverine Wolverine's
trying to embrace this whole idea of
A-frame when we were running this the
whole process it's actually a compound
first
um I'm gonna having an incoming command
I'm going to go look up the necessary
data which this case maybe it's just the
account data I'm going to go get the
account data and I'm going to push that
into
the actual message Handler
it's not exactly there but you want to
put get to the point where the message
Handler the place where it's business
logic you want to try to make that a
pure function here's some inputs tell me
what your outputs are
which case is mutating the account and
then also returning hey these are the
next steps I need you to do
um being able to test this the business
logic by mostly it's not perfect yet
because we've still got an eye document
session abstraction there but mostly
being able to push hey if you have this
account and this command what are the
responses that you send back out and how
do you modify the account
taking this a little bit farther
hopefully in a month or two there'll be
an example of this that doesn't have eye
document session in there
um
being able to accomplish the same thing
when when Jim says A-frame what he means
is there is some kind of coordinator up
top that's talking to both service
providers which would be maybe your
database and your business logic
the controller up top is invoking as
necessary it's invoking the
infrastructure getting all the data that
is necessary for the business logic and
then pushing it to the business logic
Gathering the results from the business
logic and then pushing it back at the
infrastructure to make the changes
it's just a separation of
responsibilities it doesn't
automatically imply that you have to
have abstractions but still keep the
business logic away from your database
stuff
so
the approach trying to take with with
Wolverine
actually let's make it more fun
there's also the ability to do this with
middleware
trying to build that that whole idea of
A-frame architecture completely inside
of the message handling framework itself
so it's doing much more work to push
data to you it's invoking the data
and then doing the push trying to drive
again to the goal of getting very low
ceremony code
the theory is well this stuff is a
little bit better we probably issue some
of the more complicated code format
layouts I'm not going to worry about
having separate projects for data access
this or that I may even embed
functionality that is specific to a
command I may put the data access itself
directly into the message Handler but as
a separate function that can be called
separately
all right this is a theory this is the
part where I'm going to start losing
people
um but this is this is maybe an
alternative approach I am interested in
exploring over the next couple years
um again it's back to the theory keep
closely related code together try to
enable your developers to make changes
in isolation
just think about this we're using bed
bucket at work a lot of using GitHub
when you're reviewing a pull request is
it easier when there's
a few files changes or is it a little
harder to review when you get the
shotgun surgery thing where there's a
couple lines of code changing in 2030
files
maybe that's only my life but that's
what I hit
and folks I think
this first time I've done the talk I did
a little bit yesterday
um
one last thing I want to throw out
since we're getting down a little early
um
this so organizing your code I know one
of the first questions people are going
to ask is well how do you do your
folders now do you do folders by
features or whatever it's going to be
I'm also going to say I'm talking about
it with my my colleagues of work the
still going down the approach even doing
feature folders by entities by saying
all the order operations are going to be
here
I think because of the way things cross
in these cross and operations
you want to organize more on operations
than you do on a static data Centric
model view of your system
that's more likely to get you code
that's closely related together
and enable to keep you from having files
to become way too boldly bloated
all right folks
um on that one
so I think you all been to to NDC plenty
of times you know how we do how they do
the speaker evaluations so today I was
purposely trying to joust at some
software architecture windmills trying
to be provocative this is for the first
time ever I was probably actually
purposely trying to see if I can collect
some red cards at the end of this hey
I'm done I'm done speaking after this
you want to come argue with me all day
long or please don't please don't do
Uncle Bob says but um
I I am down for it I hope even if you I
didn't convince you to do anything
differently I hope at least gave you a
little bit of understanding of the
approaches you're already using maybe
some some kind of look ahead of oh
here's some potential problems we don't
have it yet but maybe we have it later
so y'all you have been a great audience
thanks for being patient with me coming
in a little bit late thank you so much
[Applause]